[Music]
today I want to talk about the hybrid
data life cycle and I'll get into what
that really means because the title is a
little bit misleading my name is Sandeep
Parikh I run the Google cloud solutions
architecture team for America's East
what I want you to sort of think about
and take away from the session is really
understanding that you know data lives
in multiple environments right it's not
just on premise it's not just in cloud
it's kind of in both places and even in
on-premise scenarios you might have sort
of core infrastructure you might have
private cloud you might have other
virtualized infrastructure the idea is
is that data is kind of spread out in a
bunch of places and what I want to do is
kind of take that fall process
particularly from the on-premise
perspective and map that to what we sort
of think of as a data life cycle through
for kind of applied scenarios or
practical scenarios kind of as i said
earlier when we open you know it's kind
of a hybrid world right whatever you
want to call it hybrid heterogeneous
multi-cloud you've got applications and
infrastructure kind of spread out across
a number of different environments right
how many of you have a scenario kind of
similar to this that you're running into
at your own organizations you've got
multiple environments you've got data
spread out across different ones each
one is sort of satisfying different
workloads the problem is it's hard to
kind of wrap your hands around all these
things in one place so how do you kind
of tackle those problems as it relates
to things like you know processing big
data or handling you know large-scale
ingest coming in from applications or
from devices right that's the sort of
stuff we want to try to unpack and
figure out as best as possible why do
you even consider going down this hybrid
wrote like why would you even look at
this right everything is great on
premise we should have stay there
forever let's never leave but the
channel you know the reality is that
there are a lot of challenges when
you're in a non-prime environment right
you've got things like maxed out
resources that means if you want to
deploy new applications if you want to
deploy new features or functionality
you've got to pull those resources back
from something else and you know perhaps
pale and latency your throughput penalty
right that's not a great option you
might just have generic sort of compute
limitations right people might have to
wait in line to run big processing jobs
and what not
and ultimately what that sort of adds up
to is sort of the third item which is
the time it takes to kind of get
meaningful insight and understanding
auditory data and deliver that back not
only to the business but to your end
customer its pretty long right you're
trying to get out of this cycle where
you're bumping up against the ceiling of
what you have access to and you want to
be able to get information and
understanding back out to every part of
the organization and against your
customers as quickly as possible all
right so what are the approaches you
could take so the one you know that
people always think we're going to tell
them is just pick up everything put it
in a truck and drive it over to gcp and
while that's perfectly fine if you
really want to go down that road it's
not without its challenges right and we
could I contribute eyes a bunch of the
details but the reality is that that
approach is really hard if you try to
pick all that stuff up today and move it
to the cloud you're going to have
trouble right people are going to be
unhappy things are going to break
ultimately what might happen is you
might drop data on the floor you might
build one off migration processes that
aren't going to scale over time you're
going to run into a lot of rough edges
and frankly you're just not going to be
happy so instead of trying to say let's
move everything over you know go whole
hog right off the gate instead let's
find ways to sort of bridge the gap
right let's let's move certain workloads
that make sense let's try to find an
easy on ramp and let the cloud would be
your place for like you know scale new
applications you know compelling
functionality that you couldn't do
because you're maxed out and on-premise
scenarios all right so what does the
data life cycle right or at least what
do we think of the data life cycle as
though it's basically four main steps
right you've got ingest and that's you
know data coming out of applications
dating coming out of devices mobile
applications what have you but that data
is coming into your infrastructure in
some meaningful way so the first thing
your ideas you're going to capture all
that stuff and you're going to store it
somewhere you might store that in a
variety of databases it could be
anything to like you know objects log
files into something like like an object
storage infrastructure it could be
relational data it could be semi
structured and go into you know either
key value document wide column database
infrastructure and then you've got to do
something with that data right you want
to actually turn through it on some
meaningful way and start extracting a
little bit of value out of it so you
want to go to that step of processing
all the data joining things together do
you normalizing think of sub cases and
then analyzing it and then you get to
the last step where you get to really
and visualize that data and that's you
start generating that really sort of
deep intelligence about what your
organization is really doing so if you
take those kind of four steps in you and
you map them onto for kind of what I
call kind of practical scenarios that we
talk about a lot with customers what
does that look like so the first
scenario is kind of basic right you've
got on prem relational infrastructure
but you need to kind of adopt a data
warehouse approach right you need
something that's going to let you scale
out a lot and it might not just be one
database in Frank Frank you know frankly
it probably isn't just one database it's
probably a dozen or so sort of despair
it kind of you know distinct sources of
data to sync data types but you've got
to put all that stuff together in order
to get an understanding of your business
from a number of different angles so one
is again moving on prem relational to a
data warehouse and that's kind of under
the sort process phase and under the
explorer face right of the data life
cycle the next one is migrating Hadoop
and spark workloads to the cloud right
this is usually easy low-hanging fruit
for a lot of people because they can
just pick up their jobs and move them
somewhere else but we're trivializing a
pretty critical detail which is those
big data deployments on premise usually
have a lot of data and it's not like you
can turn off the sources of data one day
move everything and turn them back on
its that data is coming into the system
on a regular basis so you have to find a
way to move everything once in one fell
swoop and get that current ongoing
incremental transfer to make sense and
that kind of falls into those sort of
the process and analyze phase of the
lifecycle the other one I want to talk
about is cloud applications plus on-prem
data listen I'll be honest with you not
every data source not every application
frankly is a good fit for cloud there's
a lot of stuff that might have to stay
on Prem for a variety of reasons it
could be compliance it could be you know
sort of in-depth security concerns you
might have it could be you know other
business requirements that that we might
even know about but the idea is that
there are some things that might have to
stay there so how do i enable
development teams to deliver a new
features and functionality right to a
wide variety of customers but still
having access to that data that sits on
Prem right how do I front that for them
so they can go build something
compelling while still not really
upsetting the balance of what's here on
premise so that's kind of in the ingest
and store phase of the of the life cycle
and the last one is kind of same thing
right inside of the ingest in-store
phase but think back to those kind of on
Prem challenges where you're maxed out
on resources what if you have an
insanely great you know I OT idea
tomorrow you've got this compelling
hilariously compelling you know
connected light bulb and you want to get
these things out you're talking about
millions and millions of households with
you know 10 20 30 bulbs in there that's
a lot of data right that's a lot of
events being generated a lot of on and
off switches that are controlling these
things that are pushing data through you
might not have enough infrastructure up
infrastructure to actually take all that
data in so where's it going to go right
you've got to put that stuff somewhere
but you've also got a member remember to
enable the business to learn from that
right there might be internal
applications again living on Prem that
need access to this data so how do you
kind of facilitate that sort of you know
and circuitous kind of life cycle there
around around where the data is going to
go and how you get access to it so those
are the four workloads that kinda want
to talk about a little bit in depth and
how you sort of tackle each one of them
the important thing to remember is that
in all these scenarios you've got to be
heterogeneous hybrid multi-cloud
whatever you've got to be friendly to
this concept which means and again I'm
not going to go through all this right
now in this talk but you know definitely
come find me afterwards there are a lot
of concerns that are sort of you know at
the foundation level there right like
how do you handle security how do you
handle governance ownership you know who
has identity and access controlled all
these things those are already important
things to think about and it's critical
that you work through those open items
before you go down this road because
once you do that then you've opened the
door to you know to kind of scaling on
both sides but again you've got to take
on this sort of heterogeneous lifestyle
approach to the world and then frankly
you've got to have this thing be
scalable because otherwise what's the
point right if you can't scale it on on
a cloud environment or a public cloud
then this approach really is going to
work in any of these cases alright so
let's dig into each one of those
practical scenarios and kind of walk
through what they look like tactically
all right so the first one is on prem
relational to cloud data warehouse so
it's really simple just do this right
and that's it that's the talk is done no
kidding the idea is you've got to get
database and frankly again databases but
I didn't want to fill up too many too
many
on the slide but you've got multiple
databases you want to get into some like
bigquery because you want to be able to
do ad hoc sequel you want to explore
that data you want to look at it
normalizes you normalize you want to cut
it up and slice it up you want to build
compelling reporting and dashboards on
top of all of your despair data sources
well how do you go from on-prem to cloud
in that case so the the first thing
we're going to do is we're going to
we're going to put Apache beam in here
and I'll talk a little bit why about why
beam is a good choice all right so beam
is a very modern approach to data
processing it's very pipeline centric so
as data comes into the kind of pipeline
you create you can apply a series of
operations to it and at any point that
pipeline you can break out and dump
things wherever you want to but the idea
is you can have a pipeline that starts
with multiple data sources and funnel
them through and again do things like
in-flight aggregation you know if
there's time fields in there you can
start windowing some of that data
basically you can etl that data into
whatever format it takes but what's
really interesting about apache beam is
that it unifies the model between batch
processing and stream processing so for
example today the problem you might be
solving is I've got a bunch of databases
and I want to et al de mando some kind
of cohesive data warehouse structure and
that might be a batch job but tomorrow
you might say I'm moving that too and
i'm going to start including streaming
data sources the great thing about beam
is that there's pretty much no change to
your code you effectively have to change
the inputs to your code and say this is
a streaming source vs. a batch source
and your code just works the same way at
that point right there's no real change
and that's really powerful concept to
work through beam is also really
compelling because it's portable across
a number of runtime environments if
you've already got a yarn cluster
running MapReduce or spark on premise
beam can sit right on top of the spark
and run on top of spark or can actually
run atop a flink as well and then when
you want to get into the cloud
environment beam can actually run in the
cloud dataflow service that google
offers and i'll talk a little about that
as well and right now as of today
actually beam supports building
pipelines in Java or Python so you have
that ability to kind of mix and match
depending on what makes sense for the
skillset that your teams have
so Apache theme is really interesting if
you kind of go way way way back into
like the early 2000s you know back when
Google only wrote research papers and
didn't really build kind of public
facing products around them MapReduce is
one of the first papers not let's say
MapReduce and gfs Google file system or
one of the first two papers that I think
really came out and helps sort of kick
off you know a whole host of other
research at Google and a bunch of things
that ultimately became part of the
Hadoop ecosystem so if you think about
again Google file system that was
basically what became HDFS the MapReduce
paper is what became Hadoop and sort of
you know the follow-on between you know
MapReduce one point oh and sort of the
yarn approach that came in to dupe to
but there's a strong lineage here for
Apache be to build on top of and in fact
over the last few years google has
actually moved away from MapReduce
internally into a number of other tools
not just you know a new distributed
storage approach but also a distributed
computing processing approach and the
product of all those things over the
last few years was something we called
cloud dataflow cloud dataflow came out I
think maybe 18 months ago and it was
great it's a very powerful tool but what
we saw was the need for adopting a more
open source mindset because we want to
see dataflow be successful we want to
see but even more than dataflow we want
to see the idea of batching stream
processing become successful right from
the few defied codebase so what we did
is we took data flow we split it through
the two things out one is the service
that we run for you and the other is the
SDK portion which is what became Apache
beam so now what you can do is you can
write your pipelines and apache beam
fully open source under apache and then
run them spark slink or on data flow so
you get a ton of portability for runtime
which is a really powerful concepts
because again as you think about this
world where you started from on Prem and
you were slowly making your way into the
cloud you're not going to dump those
original data sources they just might be
located different place they might be
running on gcp inside of things like
cloud sequel cloud storage BigTable
cloud datastore cloud spanner even but
you still want to use the same beam
pipelines so instead of running them on
premise on top of a spark or foot
cluster you can actually run those beam
pipelines it inside of dataflow so
that's where at some of the history
around that
beam it's actually again pretty cool it
has four main modes of operation very
classically a big batch job the ability
to do windowed batches if you want to do
it by time or by data set sizes you can
also do things like streaming again out
of the same on the same code base or
streaming plus accumulation which is a
little bit in the weed so we won't spend
a ton of time on it so this is an
example of a beam pipeline and on the
Left I've got the batch of versions and
the right I've got the streaming version
and if you look I only really had to
change three lines of code to make this
work there's a little bit left out here
a glaze over a handful of detail but the
important thing is that I went from a
file-based input which is a batch source
and a foul based output to a streaming
and putting a streaming output just by
changing the inputs and outputs nothing
else in the middle there had to change
as far as the functionality goes so when
you think about running beam pipelines
and data flow what are the advantages
why would you even go down this road and
it's really important to understand that
you know we take the idea of kind of
managed services and manager
infrastructure very seriously we think
it's a really critical component of how
cloud should work and be built and we
want to see people be successful without
having to sit there and you know fiddle
with individual VMs and to worry about
scale up and scale down in a lot of
these examples so dataflow lets you take
a beam pipeline you push it to the data
flow service we scale up that pipeline
and scale it down for you depending on
what the input looks like so if you're
streaming data in and we see the volume
of the streams start going up we'll add
more infrastructure as we see the volume
of the stream go down will reduce the
infrastructure just like the data set
sizes if you're doing in batch mode if
you see that you have a lot of data
coming in right if you've selected a
data source that's got a lot of data set
size to it we'll go ahead and give you a
much larger cluster and you have the
ability to control sort of min and Max
there about how you want to handle it
and how quickly you need to data back
but the important thing is that you
don't have to go and actually provision
and configure those virtual machines we
do all that for you and then there's
other great things like built-in you
know kind of you I from monitoring and
understanding your pipeline and
debugging it and then we do a bunch of
other stuff on top of that as well so
two things that we've added recently or
that we've done kind of more depth into
recently our templates and orchestration
with templates you can actually define a
series of inputs in your code that you
want us to be able to template eyes and
parameterize at runtime so instead of
having to push your job every single
time we want to run it with new
parameters you can stage the job once
tell us which parameters can be adjusted
and then you can launch this from either
the UI or from the API just by passing
in the new parameters every single time
and I'll just jump ahead for a second
but this is what it looks like to create
a template right you've got to add a
little bit of metadata into your code
around all the parameters you're going
to supply and then we can go ahead and
make it really easy to again run from a
staging environment very very quickly if
you kind of take that idea back to
orchestration what happens is you can
start coming up with really compelling
ways to sort of get your pipeline up and
running right if you've got a template
eyes data flow job or a beam beam
pipeline that you've staged and data
flow and you want to maybe kick off a
job every time you get a pub sub
notification or you want to kick off a
job every time a new log files put into
cloud storage or certain rows are added
to a cloud sequel table you could do
that really easily and you can
orchestrate a few things like App Engine
with cron or through cloud functions and
both of those can actually just go ahead
and kick off a dataflow job just for you
again without having to stage and upload
jar files and push those things out so
that's a pretty compelling way to kind
of run on the template front we have a
couple of baked examples that are in the
docs like work count and cloud pub/sub
the bigquery work count is you know
certainly the hello world of the Apache
be a more data flow but actually cloud
pub/sub the bigquery is a very common
thing we see people want to take
streaming pipelines and go straight to
bigquery with just a little bit of
transformation and so that's an easy one
that you can try out as well all right
so that was the first one kind of moving
on prem relational to cloud and again
you know there's a ton of detail under
the covers there so if anybody has
questions on this I urge you to hit the
mics or find me after the talk I'm happy
to walk you through some of the things I
left out so the next one is migrating
Hadoop and spark workloads to the cloud
right that's a very popular one
migrating the Hadoop and spark parts to
be totally honest with you trivial super
easy all right you've already got jar
files built you might have some
supporting libraries that have to go
with them but ultimately you have to
deploy those jobs on us as a post
pointing Imperial local yarn master
that's not the hard part the hard part
is moving data right you've got
gigabytes petabytes of data stored in
HDFS how do you actually physically
truck that over to us well not
physically but I just actually move that
data over to us in a reasonable manner
that again not just one time because one
time is easy it's one time plus the
ongoing transfer and for that you know
we have a couple of great partners in
attunity and when disco who are
downstairs by the way on the first floor
they would love to talk to you more
about this but basically they have
software that you run on premise that
lets you feel silat 8 the one time
transfer and the ongoing incremental
transfer and that's really important
because if you kind of go back to what I
said earlier and this is a kind of a
personal philosophy of mine I hate
telling people to move everything in one
fell swoop one fell swoop is not easy
right it's pretty hard and it's a lot of
pain you're better off trying to find an
approach that lets you slowly make the
transition and then lets you run really
fast if you try to do everything at once
things don't work well you're much
better off trying to find an approach
that lets you start slow and keep
running faster and faster and faster and
then over time you can get rid of the
on-premise HD if that's cluster once
you've made that transition and you've
migrated data sources and ingest over to
cloud as well all right so let's say
we've done this process we've got the
backs transfer going we've got the
incremental transfer going what does it
look like when you're starting to run
cloud data proc which is our management
Hadoop and spark service data Froch is
kind of cool right we do oh we do a lot
of work and this is kind of another core
philosophy of Google Cloud we do a lot
of work to separate storage and compute
we want them to be able to scale
independently so instead of having you
run HDFS on gcp we tell you to run cloud
storage right Club storage is always on
always available you know all the nines
you need on availability the idea is
that you do all your storage that you
would typically have done in HDFS inside
of cloud storage and you spin up Cloud
Data proc clusters for Hadoop and spark
to actually do the compute aspect of
your job Cloud Data proc lets you spin
up compute jobs or compute clusters i
should say in about 90 seconds and
that's true of clusters that are
anywhere from 10 nodes to a hundred
notes to a thousand notes to even larger
right and if you start to think about
that a thousand nodes with 64 course
each it's a lot of that's a lot of CPU
powers you can get or if you're thinking
of you know spark from a ram perspective
that's up to 400 16 gigs of ram per
instance that's running out there so
it's a pretty big number you've got a
lot of memory head room to work with and
those clusters actually do spin up in
about 90 seconds it's probably on the
order of like 70 to 90 seconds but we
kind of say 90 just in case there's a
hiccup somewhere in there to give us a
little bit of room ahead room and aunt
club de derp rocks got built in kind of
monitoring you know logging that sort of
thing and the best part is that you get
to follow the same open source train so
if you're familiar with like the Apache
big-top project it's kind of this idea
where they sort of draw a line in the
sand around all the versions of the
software and call that a particular
release and it might be hid dupe 2x
something spark to dot something pig
hive etc that's a big top early so we
follow the big top release train which
is a similar to what like Hortonworks
does as well in practice data proc is
actually kind of cool as well because
you can resize clusters on the fly
including not just the number of nodes
in there but things like attached disks
or if you want to adjust that way the
networking layout is on your cluster we
also have custom vm so if you want to
skew higher on memory and lower on
course for example like in the case of
spark workloads that's certainly
possible you just tell us the shape of
the vm you want and we'll use that for
the worker pool the third point and this
is what i think is the most compelling
one about data proc is the ability to
use pre o'toole virtual machines so just
by a show of hands who's heard of
preemptive bulls in the room okay so a
fair amount so just real quick
preemptive O's are super powerful this
is a machine that we can give you for up
to 24 hours right after that we can take
it away at any time but the idea is that
it runs at eighty percent off list price
there's no limitation on configuration
right it's the same exact vm to get
access to accept you know we can just
kind of we can preempt it basically
within a 24-hour window now if you think
about how that maps back to your jobs
instead of running a job that takes two
days on 100 nodes why not run that job
that takes less than a day on 200 nodes
or 500 notes or
thousand notes because you're running
with a dramatically reduced cost you can
actually dramatically scale up your
cluster size and get the compute job
done that much faster and on top of that
we actually have permitted billing which
means every minute you shave off that
runtime means that much less you're
spending so it's an important kind of
metric to start thinking about how to
map your your compute jobs around and
then on top of the you know the other
bittering critical part of data proc is
the ability to bootstrap or cluster
right because we know you're not just
probably going to run MapReduce or spark
kind of in a vanilla form you're
probably going to want to tweak those
things so not only in tuning cluster
parameters but also the ability to
install things like Kafka or Jupiter or
zookeeper or any other kind of open
source packages we have a bunch of
pre-existing bootstrap templates to do
all that stuff and then we give you kind
of easy instructions on how to bootstrap
it with your own custom software so if
you've got custom jar files you want to
spread across the cluster or custom
applications that you built you can push
those out pretty easily as well the one
thing to take away that I would urge you
all to take away from this from this
idea around cloud data proc is this
transition from being a cluster centric
approach to a very job centric approach
instead of saying listen I have a
hundred note Hadoop cluster that
everybody shares and we're all going to
try to fit into it and make sure we can
get all our work done in a reasonable
time instead you shift your thinking you
sort of turn it on its head and you say
what if every job could just have a tone
cluster right what if every job could
run as fast as they wanted to and get
done super quickly what could what kind
of impact could that have on your
ability to use your data in a meaningful
way so that's the idea with Cloud Data
proc we want people to move away from
this notion of having to run a single
large stateful cluster all the time and
instead make them move to a very job
centric approach because now you're
letting everybody scale themselves
individually and again if you start
taking advantage of things like
pre-emptive will VMS custom vm sizing
you're getting kind of the most optimal
deployment the most optimal compute
cluster for the needs of that of that
job and that's really important and that
that has a lot of impact again on on
what you could have done in the past on
Prem was sort of a limited amount of
resources vs. and you know incredibly
elastic set of infrastructure inside of
a cloud
alright so that was the second one the
third one is this idea of exposing
on-prem data to cloud applications right
you want the cloud applications you want
the part that responds to like customer
requests in what the parts that interact
with mobile devices or back those
services you want those to be as
responsive and scalable as possible so
you very often we see this where people
want to deploy applications their
developers want to be able to work with
new infrastructure so they'll use cloud
to deploy applications into but they
still need access to data that's on Prem
so how do we facilitate that all right
so here's the diagram and I'll go
through this in depth a little bit so
the first one is you've got to get the
network infrastructure spun up right
it's not just about having you know good
connectivity with all your applications
talk to each other in a cloud or all
your stuff that's sitting on Prem
talking to each other you've got to
facilitate the connection between them
that's the first most important step and
we do that with two critical components
the first is interconnect right cloud
interconnect let's let's basically us
Google and y'all find a common
third-party partner like an Equinix or
an l-3 and facilitate low latency IP
connectivity ipv4 connectivity that's
the first most important step because we
want to maximize the bandwidth between
us we don't want the network to be the
bottleneck if we're trying to front on
premise infrastructure on-premise data
so we can get up to like 10 gig links
great so we've solved the latency
problem once we do all that what's the
next important part securing that line
right because that is a public ipv4
connectivity we can't just leave that
out in the open because then we've got
you know anybody can look at that data
passing through there and we want to
secure that as best as possible and make
sure the only traffic that we want to go
through that pipe is ours on and you
know yours and ours alone so we do that
with VPN right we have cloud VPN on our
side and we have a VPN gateway on your
side and we chose to get those to talk
to each other and it's a pretty simple
stuff we do this in via the API via the
g-cloud tool deployment manager whatever
the case may be it's a very simple stuff
to just spin up the VPN gateway on our
side and have it talk to yours once
you've done that we've got a secure low
latency link between us if you skip this
step everything else kind of falls apart
so this is critical and it's important
and it's kind of useful in a lot of
other scenarios as well so it's
important to kind of explore this as
you're trying to make this move into gcp
in general
but after networking the next we want to
do is front on-premise data I like using
Cooper at ease because it lets me write
applications in one place and deploy
them somewhere else on any Cooper neighs
cluster so in this example I use Cooper
days it can really be anything but the
idea is that we've secured the link we
want to give it a new application to
access to this data but we really don't
want to give them like direct direct
access to the data let them go through a
credit AP I let those connections be
audited right let those queries and jobs
be audited like them get logged very
well basically give them a modern API on
top of you know on-prem data
infrastructure that might be older might
be newer doesn't matter but give them a
consistent API to work off of let that
front your data sources and it's
important you know to think about that
because one certainly follows like a
modern development paths if you kind of
take this rest api approach to it to the
world but also as i said earlier it give
you an opportunity to monitor very
closely how that data is being used and
where you can make optimizations if you
give people sort of direct access the
database you might not have as much
granular controls you want to have or
you might be punting the access control
problem back to a database maybe to a
system that can't support it so it's
kind of cleaner separations I have this
little API this thin layer that sits you
know a look a little shim that sits
between the database and new
applications and then the second thing
or the next thing is spinning up the
cloud application infrastructure I
picked a container engine here but it
could really be anything it could be a
pension it could be applications running
on compute engine doesn't matter but the
idea is that let us handle the scale
part of the problem use our l7 load
balancer right to get one global IP that
works everywhere let that be the thing
you give out to DNS infrastructure send
all your traffic to those applications
and let us manage the scale at the scale
out aspect and then send traffic back
when we need to get access to that on
prem infrastructure that on prem data
right the last one and this is quarter
the optional step it just depends if
you're inside of cooper Nettie's and
you're running crew grades in both
places you might not really need the
service discovery piece with something
like console very often it's the diagram
is not just simplistic it's usually a
litany of applications on both sides of
the equation that may come and go and we
may shift the approach of that we're
taking so it is nice to have
a good cross cluster service discovery
mechanism and it's hard to beat console
right it works pretty well it's got a
pretty solid following so I'd like to do
I like to go down this road pretty often
alright so that was the front thing you
know kind of on prem Dana the last one I
want to come through is scaling to me i
OT workloads right this goes back to our
kind of connected lightbulb scenario
you've got you've got all these little
devices that are generating a ton of
data that are probably going to like a
local gateway or like conductors
familiar with like the Philips hue
system they have light bulbs and they
have kind of the bridge and the bridge
is what communicates out from the home
so in that sort of a scenario this is
what it might look like we might have
the Gateway communicating with a REST
API that's running on App Engine maybe
you've got Cloud endpoints maybe you
don't in front of it but you're going to
stream data out from from all those
bulbs you want to capture all that data
but you want to make sure like we've
kind of called at the bottom that
on-premise infrastructure still has
access that data you don't want to lock
it out because you're walking out your
ability for everyone to take advantage
of it so what does that really you know
how do we do that part of the reason you
want to go down this road again it kind
of comes back to the whole on-prem
challenge piece which is use max out
resources you might not have any more
Headroom and it takes too long even if
you were able to fund all that data
through because of just generic compute
limitations so you want to try to find
the best approach hear that again lets
you take advantage of all the elasticity
and the scalability on the cloud side
but doesn't cut off people from learning
from that data as quickly as possible so
the first critical most critical
component here is pub/sub how many of
you guys have heard of pub/sub already
today how every so i can just skip this
slide right I'll talk about this really
quickly think of pub sub as a completely
management and forget to diagram right
it is a completely managed message
delivery mechanism ok we can create
things like topics and subscriptions
subscriptions can be pull or push space
depending on what the sort of downstream
end point is and if you think about
messages coming in to infrastructure we
can actually split those messages and
has multiple different mechanisms handle
them so you might have one mechanism
that's sitting there saying I'm going to
aggregate all this data in flight and
i'll write it to a database another one
might say I'm going to etl this data and
write it to a data warehouse a third one
might say you know I'm just going to
type these things back out to the pub
topic and send messages to another
application you can do all that pops up
with I think about three or four gclub
commands right create the topic create a
series of subscriptions each one of them
gets their own copy of the message so
it's a it's a pretty powerful piece and
then on top of that we have other kind
of cool interesting features like
labeling you could auto expire certain
things by default I think by default and
a subscription messages expire in about
seven days if you want to tune that you
can have the ability to tune that as
well and in fact as if I think a few
months ago pub/sub actually connects up
to Kostka so if you've got a costco
cluster running on premise you can
actually hook up to costco for in jeff's
and as an output source as well so you
can actually use that as a mechanism to
get data in and out and we do this very
awesome with customers pub/sub has a
really easy to use REST API that means
there are a ton of tools like the you
know Enterprise Service bus tools of the
world that are really critical to your
infrastructure those can actually just
access a rest endpoint as long as you
set them up correctly so they're
actually going and hitting pub/sub to
get information back out in a way that's
good and sort of scalable for them as
well all right so the idea here is that
we want to reduce time to incite so
first right we're going to have events
coming in off those light bulbs they're
going to hit the IOT gateway the IOT
gateway will send it to the API and the
APA will start this chain of events so
what will first happen is those events
get pushed individually to pub sub as
individual messages then we'll have an
Apache beam pipeline that's running
inside a dataflow take in every bit of
those streaming messages and because
it's in data flow that beam pipeline can
grow or scale as much as it needs to and
we can char tree chart and restart that
data in flight so that we're not
dropping anything on the floor and that
data flow job is actually going to do a
split right it's going to write things
out into two places the first thing it
will do is it will do maybe a little bit
of light etl transformation and kick
that stuff over to bigquery if you want
to do kind of sequel on an ad hoc or
exploratory basis later on or if you
want to build a compelling visualization
or report out of that data and then what
we might also do is write the very raw
kind of time series and use big table
for that the idea of splitting these
things out is really just by use case
right we might want to do kind of
business analysis in bigquery we might
want to use the big table kind of
storage view of the time series view as
a source for like longer term machine
learning or experimental use cases so
it's nice to have the option of not
throwing anything away not you know sort
of over normalizing the data we have got
a lot of options storage is relatively
cheap these days let's write it out in
two places and we can take advantage of
that and then the last step is the data
flow job will actually do a third output
and push things like aggregates right
you might not need to know every single
event that every single light bulb
generated from every single home that
they're deployed in what you might want
to do is roll up maybe a home and say
hey for this house we saw the bulbs
change transition or transition from
state to state may be n times and wrap
that up as a single message on one
single piece of data like a single piece
of JSON and then publish that to pub sub
and then you can have other tools like
the on-premise infrastructure read from
that pub sub topic and just get the
aggregates out so now you can start to
take advantage of the idea that listen
we're going to offload all the scale and
ingest part of this problem to cloud but
still have access to the data pull it
back out and learn something from it and
it may go back into other on-premise
applications or tools that are maybe
internal facing or even external facing
but it gives you the ability to kind of
assess what's happening in these houses
on a regular basis without losing
without losing any access all right so
we kind of went through four scenarios
we burned through a little bit quickly
because I do talk fast I apologize but
I'm happy to take questions I want to do
what I'd come to that as you think about
how do we get started here right there's
a lot of detail there's a lot of little
things you know if you take nothing else
away from from today don't hesitate to
really go down the path of understanding
network connectivity if you don't get
the network part of it right everything
goes real slow and it's really hard to
take advantage of all the scale when
something over here can run really
really fast and you might have enough
infrastructure that runs fast but the
pipe between the two is slow or it's you
know you're dropping packets or it's not
secure right that's a critical part the
network is very very important as you
think about it and then you know find a
workload and each scale I'm pretty
positive that every single one of you
could come you know stand up and tell me
at least one workload that you've run
into that is running out of scale in the
current approach
right you need more Headroom to go
faster then you've got to think about
you know how do we actually make that
move do we have to migrate data switch
to migrate applications you know do we
have to point data that's coming in to
cloud and have it go through that
approach but you've got to find
something that makes sense and figure
out what your migration strategy going
to look like and then you want to test
and scale it out and then figure out
which metrics are which kind of KPIs are
really important to understand and say
this is successful or not successful or
we have to integrate and then the last
thing is really frankly be agile be open
to shifting the approach and finding new
ways to do it but use mechanisms that
are really easy to iterate around things
like pub/sub and cloud storage are super
easy to work with because you can kind
of put data in in a pretty generic way
and then you have a lot of capabilities
to move things around and reformat what
those look like all right a couple of
other sessions i would suggest you guys
you know consider looking into as you're
here today and tomorrow so one is open
source data processing on gcp it's going
to go into depth on beam and Hadoop and
spark running on Google Cloud the next
one is migrating data warehouse to
Google bigquery right that's been really
important one that's kind of dovetails
right on the first example we talked
about migrating row on purim relational
to cloud data warehouse and then the
last one is large-scale data in just
right this is true for applications
mobile devices IOT what have you if you
have a lot of data coming in how do you
do it again in depth on gcp
[Music]
you